aujourd'hui j'ai 400 chèvres laitières
150 chevrette en renouvellement
pascal ug est un agriculteur heureux
pour la journée régionale catherine il
accueille des collègues de tout le
centre val de loire et affiche fièrement
son appartenance à l'appellation selles
sur cher
cette appellation d'origine protégée
symbolise même la réussite de son
exploitation
nous sommes ici sur une zone aop celle
sur terre et cendres de touraine donc
c'est assez dynamique assez porteur ça
fait déjà plusieurs années qu'on
travaille sur le lien au terroir avec le
fourrage condamne aux animaux comme vous
pouvez constater derrière moi d'ailleurs
entre autres on essaie de tracer
justement ce lien au terroir venue de
l'indre céline dubois produits pour
l'appellation sainte maure de touraine
c'est l'une des cinq aop régional en
fromage de chèvre ce qui place le centre
val de loire en tête des régions
françaises sur ce terrain ce choix
qualitatif a permis de développer la
majorité des 700 exploitations caprines
du centre parce qu'on a la chance dans
notre région d'avoir 5 arte et ça permet
d'avoir une valorisation du lait qui est
vraiment très importante au niveau du
prix et au niveau aussi du plaisir
de faire notre métier derrière on a le
plaisir d'avoir un produit de qualité
tous les indicateurs sont au vert mais
il faut sans cesse préserver ce bilan
pour maintenir l'image positive de la
filière le syndicat des producteurs
travaillent désormais sur les nouvelles
attentes des consommateurs
je pense à aussi aujourd'hui qu'on
s'approprie tout ce qu'on appelle enjeux
sociétaux au travers on se dirait de la
biodiversité du bien-être animal
voilà des aspects environnementaux noé
op faut que ce soit aussi je dirais le
le fer de lance en termes d' exemple en
voilà qui qui qui emmènera l'ensemble
l'ensemble de la filière sur les
produits voilà qu'il soit aujourd'hui
dans l'acceptabilité de notre société
d'aujourd'hui
la seule inquiétude concerne la
transmission des ferme caprine la
pyramide des âges va imposer la reprise
d'une centaine d'exploitations d'ici
2025 et la croissance de la demande en
lait de chèvre nécessitera plus de 79
heures supplémentaires